The top sports stars get there
with a lot of coaching -
not just physical
but also psychological.
I work with sports people
all the time,
and here are a few secrets from
the world of sports psychology.
And it turns out, these tricks are
equally relevant in everyday life.
So next time you feel
really nervous, try this.
It might sound a bit strange,
but I promise you it works.
Tell yourself:
“I am not nervous, I am excited!”
Why does this work?
Well, we all get anxious
and nervous at times -
totally normal.
The tendency of course
is to tell yourself to calm down.
Sounds like a good idea,
but having butterflies
in your stomach,
and that sense of anxiety,
is just so far removed
from a state of calm,
your body just won't buy it.
Reframing anxiety as excitement
works because both
are states of high arousal.
But while anxiety is negative
and will hamper your performance -
you literally feel under threat -
excitement is an emotion
that will help you feel positive
and look forward to the challenge.
In the words of Britain's most
decorated Olympian -
with six gold medals -
track cyclist Sir Chris Hoy:
All athletes learn
how to take care of themselves.
But as important as
taking care of yourself
is learning to let others
support you along the way.
In 2019, Kenyan long-distance
runner Eliud Kipchoge
broke the two-hour marathon record.
But, he didn't do it on his own.
On the day of the event,
he had help from 41 pacemakers,
and of course the support
of thousands of people
who came along to cheer.
Kipchoge asked for
the general public to be there
because he knew he could
run better with their support.
Who can you ask to support you
in your everyday life?
There is no shame in getting help
when you're trying to achieve
something difficult.
Asking for support
is a sign of strength,
and positive support is priceless.
Many of the world's top athletes
use visualisation techniques
before a big event -
they're mentally rehearsing
it in their minds.
This can increase motivation,
build confidence
and improve your performance.
The more realistic this visualisation
and preparation is,
the more successful it will be.
Athletes will think about the sounds
they might hear - like the crowd.
What they might smell -
like freshly cut grass.
And imagine what
they are going to see.
And how they might feel.
Runners might visualise
difficult parts of their race.
Before becoming the fastest
British woman in recorded history,
Dina Asher-Smith had already raced -
and won - multiple times in her mind.
She said:
So next time you have something
to prepare for -
like a job interview or an exam -
visualise exactly how you
would like it to go.
Think about what you expect to see,
to smell, to hear
and how it will make you feel.
Identify any mental challenges
and how you could overcome these.
So that when you come to do it
for real, you are fully prepared.
Negative thoughts reduce confidence.
This happens to everyone -
even the greatest athletes.
But they have learned
techniques to overcome them.
One technique is called self-talk -
literally talking to yourself.
This can have a surprising effect
on your performance.
Top athletes will often
be heard saying,
“You got this."
"I can do this.”
It helps them to control anxiety,
to build their confidence
and to provide focus.
Muhammad Ali, often considered
the greatest boxer of all time,
was famous for saying:
But interestingly, he admitted
repeatedly saying this phrase
to himself long before
he became successful.
You don't need to say much.
Use small phrases like:
“You are ready.”
“You are good at this.”
So, next time your brain tells you
you can't do something,
just think of Muhammad Ali
and tell yourself: